we have this myth that as we increase
the size of our data sense machine
learning is going to solve all of our
problems but this is predicated on the
assumption that the quality of the
labels in our data won't go down as we
increase the size of the data which is
entirely untrue in medicine so in
physical out we are trying to build a
platform that could be used to create
the gold standard of labeling on the
medical data we want to improve the
quality of the labels that the experts
create at the same time that also feeds
into better quality of algorithms that
predict and create these labels
automatically so we started building
this on on Azure so it meant that we
could react instantly to anybody
uploading data it meant that we had a
lower cost solution because we're not
managing it locally the goal of my PhD
project is to create a seizure detection
and prediction model by using signal
processing and machine learning
techniques the main problem in my
project is to handle inter subject
variability between their patients we
run our deep learning codes on Azure and
due to higher speed of Azura it could
help us to to run our code when you go
and see that you are sort of creating
the future of medicine in a certain way
it just gives you a lot of excitement
and fulfillment out out of what you do
you